when we set out to reboot Gauntlet we
wanted to recapture the fun and
excitement of the 1980s original arcade
classic like the original arcade game
this rebirth is a four-player
cooperative dungeon crawler involving
four distinct heroes like the classic we
have Thor the warrior armed with an axe
he uses brutal close-range melee strikes
including a spinning attack that turns
him into a whirling tornado of death
Thyra the Valkyrie is armed with a spear
for frontal charges as well as a shield
that blocks assaults and becomes a
destructive boomerang and thrown quest
or the elf is precise in his strike and
can release a volley of arrows and drop
tactical bombs the elf can also utilize
a rolling tumble to quickly dodge
attacks and traps and Merlin the wizard
who has a variety of magic attacks to
choose from he can blast his adversaries
with many spells including comets of
molten lava shards of ice and arcing
bolts of Chain Lightning some abilities
can even be upgraded through perks for
example quest doors bombs can be
upgraded and attached to arrows
siress shield can be improved to reflect
enemy fire
in the backstory of gauntlet a young
wizard morroc conjures the gauntlet
seeking glory he is instead trapped
within its depths using wizardry he
calls on heroes and convinces them to
enter the gauntlet and set him free
gauntlet consists of environments like
dusty crypts dark caves fiery dungeons
and each environment has multiple styles
of gameplay some dungeon maps are hand
crafted experiences with secrets to
discover while other levels are
procedurally generated with death itself
chasing players through an unpredictable
labyrinth there are also endurance maps
filled with wave after wave of monsters
to survive inside gauntlet players will
be able to buy new armor and weapons
with the gold they acquire during
gameplay even more exciting is the
ability to unlock relics relics aware
the big powers like use a mirror relic
to create a magic army to fight in the
battle there are relics to freeze your
enemies blow them away in a tornado set
them on fire increase speed and many
more regardless of your skill level
there are thousands of ways to die in
the gauntlet to survive seek delicious
roast turkey to restore health how will
you die hordes of monsters in mortal den
devious traps or bone crushing bosses
perhaps the biggest threat your face
could be your friends competing for food
and gold beside you you're probably
going to get your fellow heroes killed
accidentally or not but that's okay
Corbett you actually get perks for dying
you'll be able to show off your status
with the leaderboards ranking your kills
loot from the fastest time replay the
Borden's treat your own scores at higher
difficulty settings September 23rd
invade the gauntlet and fight for glory
treasure and succulent turkey
you